Salut ! Nous sommes dimanche c'est donc le jour de l'explication de la semaine
et c'est la 52e vidéo du #Mentalvlog.
Je vais vous expliquer quatre techniques
qui permettent d'aboutir à un seul et
même résultat savoir dans quelle
main est caché un objet. Vous allez pouvoir demander à quelqu'un de cacher un objet
dans sa main
et vous serez en mesure de savoir
dans quelle main c'est et en variant les
techniques comme ça c'est indécelable
et c'est imparable. A la fin de cette
vidéo j'ai une grosse annonce à vous faire et une question à vous poser donc
n'oubliez pas de bien regarder la vidéo
jusqu'au bout
parce que je vais avoir besoin de
vous
de votre avis et puis j'ai surtout un
truc à vous annoncer.
Explication donc de quatre techniques pour savoir dans quelle main est caché un objet
sur quelqu'un, pour jouer à "dans quelle main ?" mais version mentaliste. Tout d'abord prenez
un objet et quelqu'un qui a deux mains. Je vais prendre un objet classique, un
dé à cent faces
si toi aussi tu passais tes nuits à jouer à "donjon et dragon" avec tes potes
envoi potes à j'ai pas de potes
parce qu'en général quand on fait des
jeux de rôle on n'a pas trop de potes.
Premier conseil c'est pas vraiment
l'explication, mais premier conseil
demandez quand même à la
personne de prendre un objet
relativement conséquent
ne prenez pas une pièce de monnaie
trop petit ou ce genre de choses en tout
cas pas pour commencer après quand vous serez bien entraîné vous
pourrez prendre de tout petits objets. Et
deuxième petite astuce soyez bien
clair et bien précis quant aux
indications que vous allez donner à l'ami
à qui vous faites ça. Première technique
et donc première explication
Pour la première technique vous demandez à votre ami de mettre l'objet
dans une de ses...  Je vais prendre autre chose parce qu'alors ça, ça va vite nous saouler !
Du coup j'en ai pris un vraiment normal
un dé à huit faces. Vous demandez donc
à votre ami de mettre l'objet dans une de
ses deux mains
vous vous retourné pour pas voir ce que
la personne fait. Quand vous êtes retourné
vous pouvez symboliser les gestes
vous aussi pour qu'il puisse comprendre.
Vous lui dites qu'une fois que c'est
fait
il mette la main qui contient l'objet
comme ceci sur son front et qu'il se
concentre sur elle.
Il faut qu'il se concentre absolument
sur la main le
plus longtemps possible,
qu'il visualise bien l'objet qui est à
l'intérieur de sa main
et vous allez le faire tenir comme ça
en parlant, plus vous le faites tenir longtemps
et mieux c'est.
Une fois que c'est fait, il doit mettre
les deux mains
devant lui comme ça
alors pas trop sur le côté, là c'est pour que vous puissiez bien voir et vous
prévenir que c'est fait. Je récapitule !
Il mets un objet dans sa main,
Il mets sa main comme ça au niveau de son front.
Vous le faites tenir, vous le faites
compter jusqu'à 15 ou 20.
Un fois que c'est fait il doit mettre les deux mains comme ça et vous prévenir qu'il est prêt.
Dès qu'il vous dit que c'est prêt vous vous retournez et vous regardez
tout de suite ses deux mains : tout de
suite, tout de suite c'est très
important parce que durant quelques
secondes
l'une des deux mains va être plus pâle que l'autre. C'est la main qui contient
l'objet car en lui faisant mettre la main comme ça durant assez longtemps vous
allez faire descendre le sang, la main
sera moins bien
irriguée que l'autre main qui elle pend
vers le bas
et au moment où il va les tendre devant
lui
il y en a un qui a un afflux sanguin
moins conséquent donc elle est plus pâle
donc c'est la main qui contient l'objet.
Et là je pense qu'on voit clairement la
différence entre la main que j'avais mis
sur le front et l'autre. C'est une
première technique très efficace mais
j'en ai d'autres !
J'en ai d'autres pour vous !!
Deuxième technique
L'indication par le nez. On appelle ça
"The nose knows" ça veut dire le nez sait.
En fait le nez sait où sont les choses.
C'est pas une technique qui est fiable non plus
à 100% mais allez vite vous y adapter et
souvent vous en servir.
Vous demandez à la personne de mettre le dé dans une de ses deux mains,
de mettre les mains dans son dos, de
mélanger et vous de l'autre côté
vous comptez jusqu'à 3 quand vous avez
dit le mot 3 la personne doit tendre les
deux poings comme ça devant elle
et penser à son objet en même
temps. Il se passe quelque chose de très
sensible
c'est que le fait de penser à la main qui
contient l'objet
(moi c'est la main droite)
ça fait pointer le bout
de son nez vers la bonne main.
C'est pour ça qu'on dit :
"The nose knows" Il vous suffit donc de
regarder dans quel axe va aller
le nez, et en fait le nez
c'est parce que la tête pointe
légèrement mais vous pouvez prendre cet axe-là.
La variation est très sensible mais si
vous demandez à la personne de penser
à son objet pendant qu'elle tend les
mains vers vous, alors ce sera beaucoup
plus lisible.Troisième explication !
Troisième technique bande de petits veinards !
Si ! Vous êtes des petits
veinards parce que la à l'heure ou je fais
la vidéo vous êtes encore dans votre lit.
Je le sais...
... je vous vois !
Si ça se trouve vous regardez même la vidéo depuis le lit. Mais enfin !
Cette troisième technique elle demande
un tout petit peu d'entraînement et
elle nécessite donc que l'objet soit
relativement gros dans la main.
Vous demandez comme d'habitude
à la personne de mettre l'objet dans une de ses deux mains, de tendre les deux poings
comme ça vers vous et vous allez
prendre le pouls de chaque poignet en
même temps. Donc
pour prendre un pouls simple vous mettez deux doigts
dessous et un doigt dessus et vous faites pareil. Donc vous lui tenez les deux
poignets en même temps et vous allez
ressentir les variations.
Mais pour réussir à sentir cette variation il faut ce que l'on appelle un calibrage au départ.
Donc avant de donner l'objet à la personne
vous lui prenez le pouls comme ceci.
Vous essayez de voir quel est son rythme
naturel ? Quelles sont ses crispations
naturelles ?
Vous lui donnez l'objet, la personne met les mains dans son dos elle
mélange elle tend comme ça
vous reprenez les deux en même temps. En temps normal il y aura pas encore de
variation, et la
vous la perturbez.
Vous lui demandez de se concentrer sur
son objet comme si il était en train de chauffer
de vraiment ressentir toutes les
sensations toute la texture de
l'objet à l'intérieur de sa main et
plus elle va y penser
plus elle va avoir des micro-mouvements
musculaires
et une petite variation dans son pouls.
Vous allez sentir ça. C'est très dur
à expliquer avec des mots
mais si vous essayez de le faire vous
allez ressentir ces variations là elles
sont très
très intéressantes.
C'est une troisième technique vous
pouvez l'essayer
c'est bluffant, même vous vous allez
vous bluffer vous même.
Et la quatrième et dernière explication pour aujourd'hui, pour ce dimanche c'est celle des yeux.
vous allez regarder la variation de la
dilatation de la pupille, simplement la
dilatation pas où par le regard juste la
dilatation de la pupille donc vous avez
la personne qui est en face de vous
vous devez bien regarder comment sont ses yeux à l'état naturel.
à l'état normal
c'est-à-dire avec la luminosité
qu'elle se prend.
Essayez d'être dans une configuration où la lumière va rester fixe telle qu'elle est.
Vous demandez quoi à la personne ? Vous lui demandez de mettre
l'objet dans sa main parce que c'est
quand même un petit peu le but de jeu
dès le départ. De mélanger, de
tendre les poings vers vous.
Mais on s'en fiche un petit peu
des poings à ce moment-là. Ce qui vous
intéresse c'est le regard de la
personne et vous lui dites "si l'objet est
dans ta main droite alors j'aimerais
que tu aies une image précise en tête.
L'image de toi
sur une plage en plein soleil
mais tu as chaud, tu as beaucoup trop chaud et tu es en plein soleil et tu regardes ce
soleil qui te cogne, qui te cogne, qui te cogne,
et t'as pas le choix t'es juste là,
c'est un peu comme des grandes dunes de sahara"
Et tout de suite vous complétez en
disant "par contre si  l'objet est dans
ta mains gauche alors j'aimerais
que tu t'imagines
dans la rue
en pleine nuit il fait nuit noire est tu es en train de rentrer chez toi avec une
personne très très très sexy (si la personne est mariée vous pouvez dire que c'est sa femme ou
son mari, moi je veux pas
d'embrouille par rapport à ça)
répéter en boucle de bien se
concentrer sur son image uniquement sur
son image parcequ'au départ la personne va forcément penser aux deux
choses que vous avez dites
ça c'est complètement normal on n'a
pas le choix par exemple si je vous dis
ne pensez surtout pas ce que vous avez
à faire lundi profitez de votre dimanche
la qu'est ce que vous faites ? Vous pensez à ce que vous allez faire lundi.
C'est comme ça que fonctionne le
cerveau il ne connaît pas la négation.
Et pour contrer ça vous lui demandez bien de se concentrer sur son image et
uniquement sur son image de vraiment se concentrer mentalement d'imaginer cette
scène
de la nourrir un maximum
et vous pendant ce temps-là vous auscultez ses yeux pas à la loupe, parce que
vous le voyez bien ce que beaucoup trop
peur
mais pour regarder vous êtes attentif
et vous allez voir de manière sensible
mais assez précise
si la pupille se dilate aussi elle se
rétracte. Si la pupille se rétracte
légèrement ou beaucoup d’ailleurs ou
fortement. C'est que la personne est en train de
s'imaginer en train de regarder le
soleil en tout cas dans un paysage très
lumineux puisque quand on a de la
lumière
la pupille se rétracte. Vous pouvez faire l'expérience, vous pouvez même vous regarder
devant un miroir et allumer la
torche de votre téléphone et la mettre
devant vos yeux et là vous allez voir ça
devient tout petit ! Et au contraire si
la pupille se dilate c'est que la personne est en train de s'imaginer plutôt dans le
noir et le
fait d'avoir ajouté quelqu'un de très
sexy c'est pas du tout anodin
c'est parce que ça provoque un petit
peu d'excitation et l'excitation
ça fait dilater (la pupille). Ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
vous ai pas donné 1 explication mais
4 explications et vous allez
pouvoir les varier ou les associer pour
être sûr de ne pas vous tromper parce
que si vous trouvez l'objet qui a dans une main c'est peut être une hasard, il y a une chance sur deux,
mais si ces deux fois d'affilée
trois fois d'affilée quatre fois cinq
fois ou à tous les coups alors là
c'est plus du hasard il n'y a qu'une seule
solution : C'est que vous être mentaliste !
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
vous allez vous servir de ça peut être
même pour bluffer les gens tout à
l'heure à votre repas à midi ou ce soir ou dans la semaine pour bluffer vos amis en
cours ou au travail ou je sais pas ou
n'importe où avant de vous dire ce que
j'avais à vous dire
n'oubliez pas si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo de la partager de parler de la
chaîne aux gens que vous connaissez
pour qu'ils s'abonnent. Quand il y a 2500
abonnés je vous le rappelle c'est mon
objectif on se fait un apéro
virtuel en ligne. C'est à dire on va faire un live de deux heures
On sera chacun chez nous on se verra on
se parlera on s'écrira
on va faire des trucs durant deux ou
trois heures j'en sais rien en live en
vidéo j'ai vraiment hâte que ça
arrive et qu'on se rencontre
comme ça par caméras interposées
d'ailleurs si vous êtes pas abonné... abonnez vous tout de suite à la chaîne
Bah oui je suis bête moi je pars du principe que si vous regardez la vidéo c'est
que vous êtes abonné, mais peut-être pas... donc
abonnez-vous à cette chaîne. Je vous en supplie !
Et la fameuse annonce
qu'est-ce que c'est ? Au delà même d'une
annonce c'est d'abord et avant tout une
question aujourd'hui on est 1515
abonnés je crois sur la chaîne je
pose la question à vous tous les 1515 et
si vous êtes pas encore abonné, vous
vous abonnez et vous répondez à la
question que je vous pose. J'ai encore
envie de lancer un nouveau format sur ce
Mental Vlog donc au départ
c'était juste une vidéo par jour ou
je mentalisais quelqu'un en fait que
je rencontrais
depuis le mercredi il y a les astuces,
le dimanche il y a une explication comme
ont vient de le faire.
Le samedi il y a les masterclasses qui sont des vidéos un peu plus longues sur un sujet
un peu plus poussé, ou il faut bosser, chez soit
pour pouvoir assimiler ça. J'ai envie de
lancer un nouveau truc le jeudi mais je
sais pas si ça va vous plaire vraiment
c'est toujours dans l'esprit du Mental
Vlog mais ça se rapproche quand même
plus du podcast en fait y'a plein de
trucs qui me passionne vous vous en
rendez compte dans la vidéo je suis en
permanence, je le vois c'est moi qui monte les vidéos,
je me vois dire "alors ça ça me
passionne..."  "Alors ça j'adore ça !"
j'arrête pas de dire ça
parce que c'est vrai je suis passionné
par plein de choses et j'aimerais vous
en parler en fait sans forcément qu'il y ait un fond
de mentalisme derrière juste pour
vous faire découvrir les trucs qui me
qui me font marrer,
qui m'interpellent qui m'intéressent
bien qu'il y aurait toujours un lien avec mes
centres d'intérêts et mes centres
d'intérêts ils tournent autour du
mentalisme. Mais la vraie question c'est
est-ce que ça peut potentiellement se
plaire en fait et ce que vous avez pas
vous dire "ah bah non ça on voulait pas ça"
Dites-moi, dites-moi dans les
commentaires dites-moi sur les réseaux
sociaux dites-moi sur facebook sur
Twitter, sur instagram, sur snapchat, sur pinterest
sur périscope sur vine oui je
suis sur tous ces trucs la oui que le
Mais dites le moi avant jeudi prochain quand même.
Passez un excellent dimanche,
bluffez bien tout le monde avec toutes ces techniques la et rendez-vous demain à 17h
pour le prochain Mental Vlog. Ciao !!